so with this you could use that for your
pajamas so this is one thing I'm so
thrilled about but use it for a boy and
you'll say Joe got this so you can rip
it on there yes pretty girl and since
she's gonna be born in football season
or heat and cleanly you're gonna have a
baby yeah we're trying to be really
creative with the items that we found
that were gender-neutral it's really
hard because some things are brown and
you're like well if you threw a bow on
it it could work for a girl you have to
show you what we got for baby oh yes I
sure don't know why this gingers
favorite of that no that's a cool okay
so they say to move that thank you
he's like your boy or girl that's like
you know it's like a football you can
pass the baby off so the next person
hand the baby off I need to take a break
I'll just baby well like when the baby
needs a diaper change or something yeah
yeah I'm gonna pass this off to you
that's good
you'll probably pass it up to me yeah
he's a beaut
no no baby so I gotta contribute somehow
yeah you will Israel's never know
I think newborn is like up to eight
pounds and he came in a mouth like nine
times I was almost 10 pounds
you're the biggest set I was nine
fifteen so Turner huh I was almost 10
pounds well mother said I think they
lied to me I think she I think you
really were ten pounds they just didn't
want to tell me they don't know were you
big baby
no I was probably seven pounds oh it's
tiny right I was nine pounds 15 ounces
you might have some big babies